And now the old scout master.
Alright, so we are ready to go, fellas.
Yes, sir,
Alrighty,
Do it.
Hey, hike on.
Well, it's time for another scout master.
Is anyone else not ready?
Sorry,
You just had to do that, didn't you?
Okay, we'll do that again.
Alright, it's time.
You've got to ask.
Come on,
Alright, everybody. now
One, two, three begin.
Hey, this is podcast number 151..
Hey,
Welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, it's Christmas Eve,
So happy holidays, everybody.
I want to thank everybody for being in touch this past week.
I'm not going to go through the mail bag this week.
We'll save that for another podcast.
We do have a scout master panel discussion that we recorded earlier this month
And that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
There's something else coming up in the new year that I wanted to mention to you:
Sunday January 13th.
That Sunday evening I'm working with a couple of people and we're working on a live web presentation
For that evening
And I'm going to have more details about that sometimes and exactly how to access it and things.
But just to let you know, put a little note on your calendar, Sunday January 13th,
And we'll have some more details about that within the next couple of podcasts.
Have a wonderful holiday,
Won't you?
Let's get started,
Shall we?
It's time for another scout master panel discussion.
It's time for another scout master panel discussion,
And joining me is Larry Geiger, down in VR, Florida.
How you doing, Larry?
Good evening, Clark.
Tom Gillard is in Tallahoma, Tennessee,
Hello Tom.
Hey Clark,
And Walter Underwood is out there in the tall trees.
The Palo Alto, California.
How you doing, Walter?
I'm doing great
High-climb.
We're moving right along here.
I had an email question that I thought would be a good topic for discussion with the panel
And let me read the email to you. fellas,
I'm a new scout master of six months and have only two years as a volunteer adult with the Boy Scouts of America and no prior experiences in scouting.
I just returned from a committee meeting where members complained that some of the scouts need to be punished for using their electronic devices to play games during yesterday's advancement meeting.
One adult suggested I make the scouts do push-ups as a punishment.
Others thought a type of reprimand or demerit system should be put in place.
I told the members that there was already a rule for scouts not to use electronic devices during the meetings and that the patrol leaders' counsel should have handled the issue.
Unfortunately, the senior patrol leader and the other leaders did not do anything to stop the scouts from playing games on their devices
And the behavior continued for about half an hour.
What would be an appropriate way to deal with this in the future?
Can the committee install a type of discipline or demerit system I would have to enforce?
Thank you for your help in this relatively simple but now somewhat complex issue.
That is a bit of a can of worms there. Who wants to get started?
There's three issues that you have to deal with. The first one is electronic devices.
You've got to talk about that. And then the second thing is punishment,
And I think that's the thing that you want to talk about.
But the third thing to talk about is that last line and that's the committee scout master relationship.
And I'll just start with that one just for a second and then let you guys go.
But no, can the committee do that?
No, The scout master is in charge of the program.
The committee chairman can certainly talk to the scout master,
But if it's not in the scout handbook and it doesn't say here's how the Boy Scout demerit system worked,
then no, the committee can't do that if the scout master and the SPL don't want to do that.
The committee chairman says: you know, you sent us a guy for a board and you didn't do a scout master conference.
The scout master says: eh, you know why do we do that.
Then he can say: wait, here's the book. But in this case scouting doesn't have a demerit system.
So no, he can't say that. So it's really up to the SPL, with the advisement of the scout master.
And it's a bad idea. But can the committee chairman do that? No,
Let's concentrate on that question for a moment.
Is it within the purview of the committee chairman to be able to set something like that
and tell the scout master it's time for him to enforce it?
Well, that was my first response too. It's like no, the committee cannot set up a demerit system.
The committee can talk to the scout master about the program,
But the scout master says: we are teaching the SPL and the patrol leaders how to lead.
And then the scout master teaches the SPL and patrol leaders: here's what you do.
So these guys are not paying attention, They're doing this and this
You need to spread out. And the next time scout master taps somebody on the shoulder,
takes them over and says whisper, whisper, whisper, let's you know, go settle this down.
so the guys are paying attention.
I say no to that also, And there have been times when I have noticed some of the youth,
some of the older scouts, doing something over on the side with a phone,
And I'll try and get the same patrol leaders' attention and point to it.
He may or may not go over and say something
And it'll go on for a little bit
And I'll sort of walk over there and look over the shoulder and see what's going on.
And they're looking up something that pertains to scouting on the phone.
That always bothers me too,
But you're old.
Yeah,
In consultation with the patrol leaders' council about dealing with this,
because it's a problem for everybody,
They knew if somebody was using a cell phone or an electronic device
in aid of what was happening or if they were just being distracted by it,
and that if they judge that somebody is being distracting
and their encouragements or directions to them go unheeded,
that that person needs to come to talk to me.
Do you guys have any specific way of handling things like that?
Well, now we're on to the first question that I listed, which is the devices,
And I disagree with you when you say everybody has a problem,
because I just ignore it.
I know on the internet I've seen conversations on various places
and everybody gets their drawers in a knot about this whole thing.
And I've ignored the whole thing because I truly believe that those guys are going to lose.
You cannot go backwards.
This thing is part of life.
They're going to have to learn how to pay attention
and get everything done, just like they did with other distractions in the world,
And I don't know how that's going to work out in the end.
but I just don't think there's any way.
I think making a bunch of rules and getting all involved in this is the wrong thing to do.
Now the scouts need to enforce amongst themselves
how they're going to deal with scouts that have an attention problem
and let them work it out.
But I think if you stick your nose in it and you get all spun up about it,
eventually those guys are just going to vote with their feet.
And those families that say:
what do you mean? my kid can't have a phone on the camp out.
That's crazy. Bye, I'm leaving.
That's their family rule.
I can't make a battle out of it.
Let me tell you this? I don't think we disagree.
I agree with everything you've said.
What I described is the way that they handle any kind of a discipline or difficulty.
If they can't correct it, I'm the next step.
Walter, what about you?
I'm a digital native, so everybody's got a phone.
Our guys, we say, maybe in the car you can chat, but put it down,
Let's go camping.
Will you go camping where there's no reception anyway?
Yeah, that's, what we've got is no reception.
Most of their parents told them to take it.
They've got it but they can't use it because there is no reception.
I don't get in a knot over them doing it,
I just sort of make it a.
If I see it. I'll just make a little point about respect
towards the same trollator and anything constructive right now,
But anyway, I don't really get upset about it.
That's one of the few things I guess.
Well, I'll tell you an interesting story.
When we got down to summer camp a year or so ago,
we were getting set up,
My parents were all over in their area
and one of my assistant scoutmasters got a phone call
and his phone started ringing there in the campsite.
He took it out and he looked at it and he said:
wow, I didn't know that I was going to get reception here,
and they must have changed the towers or something around camp.
He took the call and it was his wife, and he said:
yeah, honey, I can get a call right here in the campsite.
and then a look of horror spread over his face
And he really wanted to take those words back,
But for the rest of the week he just turned his phone off.
Well, our summer camp is up in the Sierras
and it's really it's kind of remote.
There was a cell phone bench so you can go up and around
off the trail and sit there,
and that had better cell phone reception.
When we're on long trips traveling,
having them in the cars helps keep the noise down to some extent,
But I like to use the scouts like if I have something
I would really like to tell a car, that's, you know,
the driver or another adult, to send the car behind me
or in front of me. get the scouts to be the relays,
Let them do the communicating between vehicles, and that works.
Yeah, we've done that.
What I think Clark really wants to talk about, though,
is item number two.
Yeah, and that's punishment
All right. so let's talk about that for a moment.
One person on the committee suggested doing push-ups.
How about that?
Let's just talk about that real quick.
As adults we have never, never on anything,
had any kind of punishment like that.
We've given them stuff to think about.
But I tell you, it's the youth that came up with push-ups,
especially like clearing camp before we're leaving
and making sure everything's picked up.
We tell them to sweep the camp
and then we'll come and look for trash
and see if we can find any after they do
and they go. what if you do?
And we all stand there and look at them and go.
I don't know what if we do push-ups
And we go. sure, if you want to, that's fine with us.
And we've never left a camp that they didn't have to do some.
but it's always on their terms.
They do it.
We're not making them do that.
Walter, what do you think about push-ups?
I'm a little iffy on the whole push-ups thing,
but hey, our guys do. if you're not in uniform,
as defined by the SPL,
then push-ups are. if you're not on time, push-ups.
And you know, I showed up in civilian clothes
to drop off some forms last night
and I ran out before. I had some push-ups,
But once, once everyone was in uniform
and the senior patrol did push-ups.
Well now, if the scouts but notice the sentence
it says, one adult suggested I, the scout master,
make the scouts do push-ups.
That's a different issue than what Walter's talking about.
when the scouts get together and do some you know
Yippee-ki-yay thing, some moral morale boosting thing,
That's different.
Let me be very specific about the question.
So I'll start with you, Larry.
Is it proper for an adult to impose punishment
through some kind of forced physical action like push-ups?
No,
Okay,
That's baloney.
No,
Yeah,
And Walter.
Walter says no.
So I'm kind of iffy about the scouts doing it.
I've let it ride. but
Well, I did check in the Scout Master's Handbook
because I remembered something specific about this,
And it will tell you very directly:
adults are not to impose that type of forced physical
punishment on anyone ever.
The situations you described, where this is initiated
by the scouts, I feel like you do, Walter.
I'm a little iffy about that because I can see it.
It can head over the edge real quick.
There's a game aspect to it
If they're initiating it. I'm going to side on the safe side
because we're advising people.
You would need to think long and hard about that
and you need to observe the prohibition against such things
that you'll find in scouting literature.
You can normally tell if a Scout Master's on the ball
and he's paying attention.
He can tell the difference between a bunch of gung-ho guys
and a 15, probably 16 or 17-year-old ROTC kid
riding herd on a bunch of 11-year-olds,
which is just as bad as the adults doing it.
So there's a difference and you can tell it
and you can feel it.
If it gets to the point where the PLC is up there
doing push-ups and then after they're done, they all cheer,
you can feel the difference between that and the other thing,
which is you guys get down on the floor.
There's a line and I think you've got to watch that.
Maybe I'll suggest the SPL, the senior patrol, does push-ups
unless everyone is in uniform.
Yes,
Ours is all in fun.
It's not the finger-pointing,
It's everybody. and, like Walter said,
it doesn't matter whether you can get up on the floor.
you're trying and it truly is all in fun
and we watch for that.
It's not standing over and making them do whatever it is.
I think I got that sense from you.
I'm just in an abundance of caution
because people are listening to us
and making sure that we drive that point home.
What is suggested in the question that we received?
we're not going to have that happen.
Patrol leaders, council or the boys may be real hard driving
gung-ho guys who are really doing it in a spirit of fun
and things. as long as it's not a tiresome routine
that they use to belittle or haze people,
I don't really have a problem with it.
but let's just be very, very careful
to differentiate between those numbers,
Absolutely.
There's a couple of hidden questions here.
The first one is: you know,
we talked about the advisability of the committee
trying to install a system of discipline
or a demerit system or something like that
and we agreed that that was not a good idea.
but is it a good idea to have such a demerit system
or a system of punishments or disciplines?
A demerit system doesn't have a place in scouting.
Scouting is moving forward,
Demerits are moving backwards.
If you think about it for a little while,
it's just not compatible with the overall way,
In particular some of the quotes you've had
in the last couple of things from Bade and Powell,
the last couple of posts that you've done about advancement.
scouting is moving forward.
Scouts go, they advance.
Scouts do not retreat.
They don't demerit,
They merit,
And that has to permeate everything you do.
If you start something like this,
you will end up in a mire, in a pit of mess.
There may be one or two places in the world
for that kind of thing, in certain places
where you're working with very serious life and death situations,
But in the case of education, moving ahead, advancing,
that's why advancement is called advancement.
I don't think it has any place.
That's my opinion.
It's calling somebody down in a very negative way too
and calling attention to them in a negative way,
and you really don't ever want to do that
and you always want to be very positive.
So you want the positive reinforcement versus the negative. also,
Walter, you got anything on that
Demerits? No,
We're talking about progress
Other than it being amenical to the principles
that we want to be exercising and scouting.
the other thing is, if you create a rule book like that
now that makes you a policeman
where you're going to have to be,
you're going to spend an inordinate amount of time
and your youth leaders are going to spend
an inordinate amount of time policing a bunch of rules,
when the scout law and the scout oath seem to be very adequate
to that task.
That would be what I would put into it.
The second hidden question here is:
they're having a meeting and the scouts are doing this.
so what's going on at the meeting?
that is less interesting than playing on my phone.
Well, and you got two issues there.
You got the meeting may not be theirs,
the regular stuff we talk about,
and then you may have those one or two guys
for whatever reason, no matter what your meeting is.
If Harrison Ford showed up
and the circus put on a show,
they'd be looking at their phones.
There's going to be other indications
that they're disconnected.
It's not going to just be their phone,
it's going to be behavior:
not showing up for camp out,
it's not bringing. something else is going on
and eventually that's
along with any other kind of behavior.
that's when you have to.
they're going to probably have to sit down
with a scout master and say:
what's going on here?
We need to make a deal.
Are you here because you shouldn't be,
but your dad brings you?
Do I need to sit down with you and your dad?
Do we all need to chat?
And it won't be just the phone.
it'll be four things.
I've had scouts that have already checked out
their parents suit them up, bring them down
every Tuesday at seven o'clock.
and he checked out three months ago
and I know it and he knows it
Well. thankfully, ours has been very,
very short lived.
They're talking about some game
or some viral YouTube video they saw.
They haven't checked out.
it's that little.
they're 15 minutes up.
now they moved on and a little reminder
and they focus back for a little while longer.
Thankfully, I haven't had that problem yet.
If I get to the end of a meeting
and I'm listening to the Patrol Leaders Council
and I'm hearing several complaints
about people being distracted
or not paying attention,
then my question to them is always:
well, what were you doing? that was not that interesting.
Why weren't these guys engaged?
Sometimes, that's the question to ask.
They need to make a little bit of an adjustment
in their presentation.
How are you going to fix it next week,
Right?
That's the basic thing.
Scouting is awesome.
Make it awesome.
How do you make it awesome?
I do it with a podcast.
Sorry,
I have not seen Gangum style from you.
Yes, they do.
I'm not really ready to see Gangum style from you.
If I had a clue what you were talking about,
Right?
I don't have any idea either.
Yeah,
Google Gangum style and you'll find out.
and you won't, or not.
you can do either one
Gangum.
Put a link to this in your podcast.
Gangum style? I don't think so.
Let me offer you this
and see. I want to know if you agree with me.
I don't think it is our responsibility
to punish scouts.
I think that's why they have parents.
Parents can do a much better job of it than we can.
If I have a behavior problem,
I'm going to make parents aware of it
and say that we don't discipline and punish,
but you certainly may take that option
if you feel it's merited in this instance.
We went backpacking a couple of weeks ago
and I woke up Sunday morning
to hear my troop quartermaster pretty loudly.
I heard the word matches
and I heard the word flicking
and I heard the word tent and burned.
My quartermaster was a very unhappy fellow
and it was a little while before they were presented to me,
but these guys were flicking matches in the tent
and they managed to burn it-
Not terribly, but they managed to burn it-
and of course that was a pretty serious problem.
I put it in the hands of their fathers.
when they came to pick them up from the trip.
I explained what happened
and I explained that we don't punish
and we don't discipline.
but they may take the opportunity
to see if they can figure out what happened
and they can figure out
how we wouldn't have to deal with it in the future.
I felt pretty good about handling it that way
and I didn't feel as though there was any pressure
on the troop to have to be the arbiters
of some kind of punishment or something like that.
Well, did the behavior stop
when the quartermaster went ballistic on it?
Yes, well, I think the behavior had already stopped.
I think it was discovered,
So you didn't have to get in between
a dangerous situation and the issue.
Some kind of little piece of brain
finally engaged and a clue bird landed
and they suddenly realized
what kind of condition they were in,
and after you talked to their dads
then they were starting to get a clue
In that particular case.
that's exactly perfectly handled
and probably turned out in the long run
an excellent lesson all around
for the quartermaster and for the two scouts,
and maybe even the dads,
Because they're going to own that tent with a hole in it,
with a burn spot in it, for a long time
and every time they look at it.
they'll remember what they did
that they shouldn't have been doing.
But yeah, I agree with what you've been saying,
that the troop really should not
get into the punishment business at all.
Very proud of my quartermaster:
He managed to express his displeasure
without losing his temper
and he did it in an unmistakable fashion.
I have to say.
I was a quartermaster as a scout
and I remember opening up the closet
and pulling out some Dutch ovens
and finding out that there were
some Dutch ovens with ecosystems in them
Which I hit with a hose
from a considerable distance.
I don't know what I said at the time,
but it wasn't worth many people around
Having the ability to dress him down
like you say he was doing
and not really losing his temper,
and that's a skill that will carry him far in life.
when he's able to tell people stuff like that-
and they'll thank him for doing it
Because he does it in such a good way,
They understand where he's coming from,
but he doesn't belittle them.
I think he used the word stupid several times.
Well, if you leave shrimp in a Dutch oven
and in the closet in Louisiana,
I mean stupid could apply.
Listen, we would certainly like to hear from you
and we would like to get you to come
and join us on the next scout master panel discussion.
We get together once a month
and we can have you phone in when we record,
and you're going to find out how to do that
towards the end of the podcast here,
But let me, before we go,
thank Larry for joining us this evening.
Thank you very much, Larry.
We are welcome Clark,
and I hope all you guys have a happy holiday
and a merry Christmas
and all you guys out in scouting land
maybe take a week off from troop meetings
and hang out with your wife on a Monday or Tuesday night.
But everybody, have a good vacation
and take care.
And Tom, thank you.
You're welcome, Clark,
and I'd also like to wish everyone
a merry Christmas and happy holidays
and see you next year.
Yep,
And Walter,
Well, I wish you luck with your axe murderer
and the tape to make us all sound smart,
But and have a lovely holiday.
Yeah, I'll add my best wishes in as well
for the holiday season
And we'll be back in the new year
with another scout master panel discussion.
Thanks a lot, folks,
Thank you.
Thank you for listening to this edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch.
Go to scoutmastercgcom
and there you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
and the podcast by email.
You can also subscribe to the Scoutmaster Podcast
on iTunes
and you can access the podcast
on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
You can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets:
Scoutmaster Blog on Facebook,
Scoutmaster CG on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
Scoutmaster CG Circle
Search for Scoutmaster CG on Google Plus.
Please email me, Clark Green,
your comments and questions
and wild ideas at scoutmastercgatverizonnet.
The Scoutmaster Blog and the Scoutmaster Podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
No, it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun
along the way.
So before we leave you,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Mayden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and group camping.
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.
Thank you.